all right so quite a few people were
like Jeremy talked about the PlayStation
Network being down
yeah the PlayStation network's been down
since like Wednesday a day after Mortal
Kombat which sucks cuz I gotta kill some
folk but okay so the PlayStation Network
was hacked
after that Sony takes the PlayStation
Network down there like it's hacked it's
bugged intruders alert and all that good
and immediately everyone's finger
points to this hacker named geo ha his
name's George Hotz they point to him
because he's hacked playstation stuff
before the PlayStation 3 scene is like
the unhackable system so he was like
alright that's like a challenge to me so
he hacked it he did stuff like unlock
backwards-compatibility the ability to
put your own mods on the PlayStation 3
you bought the thing why not buddy
got sued by Sony which is weird to me
cuz that's like General Motors suing
someone for souping up their car I mean
they own it they bought it when you buy
something it's not like you rent it it
is yours
I'm now being sued by the makers of
plastic forks you see what I'm saying so
Sony sues this hacker Gio hai he's like
alright I'm not gonna hack anymore you
didn't the PlayStation Network
attacked and everyone's like dude he did
it which I really don't think he did it
could be dead wrong I'm not down and
like the hacker community or anything
like that but he sees himself as one of
those V for Vendetta Robin Hood types
taking down the PlayStation Network kind
of just pissed off 70 million people so
that would be counterproductive but he
released a statement he was like you
know for once it wasn't us
so I guess they have to rebuild the
entire PlayStation Network which we've
all had a virus in our computer in which
we had to reformat our computer but
imagine that but you have to reformat it
in a way that keeps all the data and
just eliminates the bad stuff that was
sucked so five days later here we are no
playstation network and which Xbox
people are beating people up in Mortal
Kombat right now all I just dpad sucks
and so many people are like still online
okay alright challenge tower here we go
which the prize is not worth it you can
buy out the last mission for like 50,000
gold do it it'll be clear I'm not saying
mass piracy is cool or anything like
that I mean piracy stealing online
that cost like billions of dollars I
don't I'm not for that companies do have
a business to run I respect that but
hacking modding doing stuff to the stuff
that you buy modifying your own why
not but I want to know what do you guys
think about this I again I'm not really
in on the whole hacker community I know
a couple of you have to be twenty-nine
thousand subscribers no one knows
anything about hackers I refuse to
believe so let me know comment below
what do you guys think about this and
this is this geo hot guy calling him geo
hot makes me sound really gay it's his
name I didn't figure it what do you
think about it I imagine this is gonna
be
talk of the week because the PlayStation
Network is still down but there's your
little bit of news on Monday for you
guys hopefully making you guys lives a
little more fun on the worst day of the
week what if you like what you seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more